on est de retour pour vous parler d'un
blé chouchou de certains membres du
podcast et à raison puisque c'est un
joueur très intéressant qu'on va coûter
ce soir et pourtant il me jouer contre
une grosse conférence n 6 et il joue du
côté de soldats
c'est la même conférence gonzaga pour
ceux qui essayent de situer donc c'est
sur la côte ouest des états unis
s'appelle keszler edwart nuit cohen et
alan scouting report de l'épisode 10 de
notre saison 4 d'envergure et c'est
parti
[Musique]
comment ça va l'équipe ça va très bien
voire très bien aussi très très bien
également pourquoi il ya des analystes
du basket français connaissent la petite
fac de pepperdine à votre avis via
couvrir d'or un règlement c'était la fac
de yacouba dire ils vivent sur les
appuis and go
depuis que tom brady a remporté
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire qu'est ce qu'on
va faire sur kessler et noir on va
d'abord dressé son portrait parce que
franchement en toute objectivité ce
n'est pas quelqu'un au cas déjà buzz et
que ce soit dans un big board ou même
des choses un peu plus anonyme
confidentiel hipster diraient certains
je n'ai jamais vu dans un top 20 je les
ai déjà vus entre 20 et 30 et encore
c'était sur une minorité de classement
donc qui est ce qu'est ce que l'art
edwart et pourquoi on vous en parle
la question de la pause à ben casse leur
edwards
c'est un ailier de pepperdine de
troisième année
c'est un junior il fait 2 mais 3 et 91
kg il est
c'est un excellent shooteur qui est a
présentement à 47% du à 47% et à trois
points qui est à 37 points 2 %
c'est absurde moi un des cinq meilleurs
shooteurs dans la draft
s'il n'est pas aussi développé et pour
aussi réactif quincaillerie qu'espéré
par exemple mais il peut lui peut
prendre feu et il a pris feu c est
pendant les deux premiers mois de la
saison culminant le 21 janvier dernier
avec une performance absolument
étincelante contre pacifique
les matadors je crois qu'il s'appelait
37 points 11 rebonds 6 points 6 à trois
points 60% au shooting belle performance
de france et aussi deux voies le bal un
bloc
c'est un joueur ce joueur qui va être
joueur d'appoint une big votre joie de
rotation mais il a le potentiel pour
être le bon joueur de rotation puis je
crois qu'il a le potentiel pour se
développer pour être encore meilleur que
ce qu'il est maintenant
donc on nous vend à un superbe shooter
alan parle nous de son rôle du côté des
ports baigne puisque malgré le fait que
ça soit sans aucun doute le meilleur os
pète son équipe comme c'est
régulièrement qu'un ici et c'est pas
forcément lui le gotha et c'est pas
forcément lui le joueur le plus
important c'est pas lui qui a le plus
grand taux d usage du ballon dans son
équipe voilà exactement quand j'en
aurais parlé ensemble dans l'avant
saison dans les joueurs à ce tube on
avait dit que castrés rire duarte était
le meilleur prospect de l'équipe mais
que au début de la saison avant la
saison collopy ross était le meilleur
joueur sans doute de peur gagne en
terminent 6es pas dans la projection
professionnelle et donc ouais c'est une
équipe qui qui est drivée par un depuis
deux trois ans par un petit meneur qui a
un fort taux d'usagé qui crée tout c'est
une attaque assez héliocentrique en vrai
bernheim parce que baceco le biros le
petit c'est un petit bonheur c'est un
simple timone rn6 et qui fait un mât de
80 qui tire beaucoup à trois points qui
tout pas mal depuis qu'une rolls et qui
créent toutes les attaques
donc en fait questeur edwards il a le
rôle de spotters shooter le rôle de deux
jours qui sort parfois des écrans
parfois qu'ils posent des pics et qui
est d'utiliser sur votre situation de
pikine pop mais il n'a pas de la
création collective à gérer il a plus la
finition des actions et le scoring aux
côtés de du modaire qui débat a fait du
pool up fait du pick and roll et sai on
le voit aussi de temps en temps prendre
des positions à l'intérieur même qu'acer
edwards en joue 3 4 on va dire si on
devait schématiser son pote de jeu du
côté de pepperdine juste un dernier
élément de contexte à l'âme
défensivement il n'est pas forcément sur
le meilleur extérieurs ou intérieurs
adverses même si ça lui arrive ouais ça
lui arrive pas je trouve que c'est pas
une équipe qui défend très bien
personnellement ça joue assez vite c'est
ça défend pas
c'est parfois agressifs sur les lignes
de passe met en contexte collectif de
ses pas extrêmement fort trop
défensivement et aux îles a pas là en
gros si on veut la hiérarchie de
l'équipe qui a cole biros c'est le petit
meneur lui défend pas trop et crée
toutes les attaques
kessler edwards il est un peu tout et
dans l'unité qui ils vont spotter puis
défend puis comme il est long il ya une
belle envergure il fait il défend un peu
mais pas vraiment qui après à côté à 300
et à des soldats et des soldats qui sont
là pour prendre des rebonds poser des
pics défendent of gaulle et mettre des
paliers en fin de chaîne alors on va
commencer par son point fort kaka cité
ben pour nico je vais te poser de
questions est ce que pour toi
effectivement c'est également son ticket
vers la draft nba
son centre tir et qu'est ce que tu en
penses est ce que c'est un point fort
est suffisamment fort pour être vendeur
alors moi je serai là pour être le bad
cop ce qu'on est avec on avec deux
amoureux de kessler edward c'est moi
j'avoue que je préfère car stone edward
tu vois non je pense que j'aurais aimé
alex j'aurais aimé que tu démarres le
podcast en demandant à notre ami alan la
définition des lieux centric parce que
je rappelle qu'il n'y a pas que des bac
+ 5 qui nous écoutent lieu centrica lane
le centre x est un concept qui a été mis
en nba par steve barto qu'un journaliste
de 10 athlétique et qui a étudié les
attaques de atlanta sous très dallas
suzuka dont 6 h et engrossé quentin la
création collective sur demi-terrain
dépend quasi exclusivement d'un joueur
est ta réponse est merveilleuse
je t'aime en live concernant kessler
edouard ce pour répondre à ta première
question oui je pense que son shoot est
son ticket d'entrée pour la nba est-ce
que ça va être suffisant on a plein
d'exemples de personnes sur qui on
n'aurait pas parié
on pense notamment à un petit blanc du
côté de miami
enfin deux petits blancs même du côté de
miami sur lesquels le shoot a été un
ticket d'entrée et puis ils ont montré
qu'ils avaient au final qu'ils aient pas
que ça pour kessler edward va développer
après je suis beaucoup moins fan que mes
collègues mais mais je comprends
parfaitement que dans la nba moderne ça
soit un joueur soit qu'il y en ait envie
de pagnes je suis un peu dans ton équipe
des sceptiques
on devait créer deux camps je suis pas
totalement convaincu par ce shoot
j'ai l'impression qu'ils forcent qui est
un petit mouvement alors été les
premiers à dire qu'on est trop tatillon
parfois sur les sur les gestuelles sur
25 ans mais j'ai l'impression que sous
pression ça va être compliqué pour lui
de prenez l'exemple de duncan robinson
de shooter comme duncan robin stone
shoot c'est à dire rapidement et beau il
al'avantage qu'est ce qu'on va devoir de
le relâcher la balle déjà très haut
oui par contre je vois ce que ce que tu
veux dire pour ceux qui l'ont jamais vu
shooter il maintient sa balle toujours
haut au dessus de sa tête donc ça là
dessus c'est super et en fait quand il
saute une fois qu'il est en l'air il ya
une sorte de mouvement des pôles sa part
plus du haut du corps que du bras et du
coup effectivement ça donne une
impression visuelle un peu un peu
trouble par rapport à nancy l'avait même
mouvement à d'autres mécaniques comme si
poussée un peu avec le dos qui avait pas
assez de force dans les bras fin j'ai
moi je vois plus ça par rapport à la
force dans les bras que par rapport au
dos mais tu as peut-être oui oui mais
c'est possible que ce soit
alan je ne sais pas
interrogé sur le tir mais ce que tu tu
vois ce qu'on demande c'est à dire du
volume
la réussite on en a parlé mais du
holding et puis de la diversité de petit
rocher le volume ou oui la diversité non
le volume oui parce que sur ces trois
années il est toujours à plus de 4,3
points tentés par match donc il ya
toujours pris des tirs à trois points
deux volumes noms parce que selon les
stats avancé qu'on peut trouver 100 % de
ces tirs à trois-points proviennent
d'une passe cette année et ça rejoint
encore l'idée de colby ross de métronome
de l'équipe qui crée des décalages et
edward qui shoote ans potter mais c'est
96,6 pour ça ils étaient 1
vous avez trouvé j'ai trouvé un trou
grâce
bah ouais ça reste quand même un mu un
terrible non jeter à corps avec vous sur
la la mécanique c'est un peu un peu
bizarre et on a presque quoi qui se
compresse et en fait c'est il est haut
il méritait il est beau mais on a
l'impression qu'il est un peu pas hyper
à l'aise et un mouvement des jambes
aussi après il a amélioré son
pourcentage volant c'est la 83 % cette
année et ça reste vraiment un jour à 39%
à 3 points sur plus de 330 tentative en
trois saisons donc il a le
il a le volume il a la réussite l'a pas
la diversité
ici pas un joueur qui tire en sortirait
pas du tout ben je vais demander du coup
développer ton un des cinq meilleurs
shooteurs de la draft quand même parce
que il y en a des snipers on n'a pas
encore forcément parler mais les rockets
qui se perd mais on a aussi des points
de ron thomass des petits john p tit
joola a mené ce point-là plus tard par
là
dans la discussion les gars mais je
crois que c'est peut-être ça peut être
ça explique cottage seulement les plus
remarqués mais aussi que osho qui avait
il y avait certes un problème mécanique
il est temps qu'ils étaient recrutés à
peu près d'un an
il faisait un mètre 95 et 77 kg
maintenant il fait 2 m 3 effet 97 kg
donc il ya une poussée 300 ce qui je
crois a fait en sorte qu'il est
peut-être encore un peu inconfortable
dans son corps présentement mais vous
avez raison pour le manque de variété
sur le tir puis je voulais amener ce
point là aussi lui et colby oies se font
toujours le même jeu ensemble et ça
fonctionne à chaque fois la plupart de
ces tirs sont sont absolument non
surveillée parce que comme vivace a
ramené trois personnes à l'anneau avec
lui puis il rit le beau jeu est donc là
celle à qui je crois qu'il veut d'avoir
montré un peu de d'amélioration mais moi
je le vois quelquefois lorsqu'il décide
de foncer au panier lorsqu'ils essayent
de dos avait des changements de
direction dribbles
une certaine aisance justement d'aller
non sud est ouest qui me fait croire que
justement il ya peut-être justement pas
fini le grand dîner de données
confortable dans son camp ce quelqu un
qu une poussée croissance vraiment très
très tard nico il être autre chose que
en simple chauffeur
oui parce qu'il a une activité sans
ballon qui est très intéressante et du
coup il va il peut amener des cut
baseline il peut amener des des choses
qu'on va lui demander à une billets
puisque ce sera forcément pas un porteur
de balle je trouve son jeu sur pick'n
roll
rustique que ça soit des deux côtés en
attaque ou en défense
donc du coup il y aura le shoot sur à
l'activité sans ballon par rapport au
drive
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec ben
dans le sens où moi j'ai l'impression
qu'il est obligé d'utiliser le spin pour
aller au bout et que dès qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est vraiment reste face au
ballon il est en difficulté
d'accord ici c'est après c'est le cas de
beaucoup de plus en plus de joueurs
parce que la klein
c'est à dire une défense où le but c'est
quand même d'empêcher la pénétration est
de plus en plus présentes de
l'impression a essayé et ça devient de
plus en plus difficile de simplement
jouer son incompréhension ouaip je
dirais que c'est vraiment laconique on
va falloir exemple pour le sur le match
que j'ai vu quand une bagarre
il a vraiment éprouver des problèmes à
ce niveau si on regarde les matches face
aux équipes de haut niveau c'est à dire
aux gars et et du ciel est encore jeudi
de haut niveau c'est top valeur top
contre 35 pour le dit c'est plus fin
c'est peu de dire qu'il a galéré elle
mais j'ai une question justement pour
vous par rapport aux adversaires ce que
moi j'ai regardé contre san diego state
contre biais ue et puis une obscure fac
c est subie je sais même pas ce que
c'est j'ai l'impression que on est en
train aussi de juger un joueur
face à des adversaires qui sont très
loin du niveau élite colette selon le
san diego state il n'y a qu'une savoir
surtout à san diego state is ok je sais
pas si tu as des ghost et ya deux jours
que qui sont potentiellement pro je
pense dans cette équipe surtout matt
mitchell un mec un peu comme admical
superstar et jordan chacon et jorane
chacun le tout heureux mais après ouais
c'est pas assez pour c'est ce qu'on se
demande parfois aussi avec les prospects
gonzaga en vrai parce que dans leur
conférence la wct ya passé la troupe en
grèce la troisième meilleure conférence
de la côte pacifique
parce que tu as la pac toile est là
mountain aux essais devant veut c'est la
vague a dit voyons quels wcc pepperdine
sentent maryse qui est pas mal
parfois la fac avec tous les petits
australien et tout ça ouais et puis mais
oui c'est pas faux tout faut voir les
champions pour ça que c'était
intéressant de le voir face à lucie les
ai sentis et ghost est en or conférence
alors à l'aller c'est ces bikers fils de
pardon c'est l'axé road runners de
baccarat cents us
il ya beaucoup de fois que de la
banlieue de los angeles en fait dans la
vidéo ici c'est donc peut redoubler et
ceux qui sont fans de grosses bêtes à
l'intérieur à les voir revenir et du ce
vous en aurez pour votre argent
alan est le jeu offensif que kessler
edwards est il amené à se développer et
pour quelle raison est ce que tu as vu
des choses intéressantes que ce soit sur
du drive que ce soit sur du jeu au bol
que ce soit sur deux là parce qu'ils ont
du rebond offensif que sais-je
en fait je le sais un jour que je trouve
à l'écran il fait plus long est grand
que ses mensurations de leu leu
l'indiquent
c'est cette impression là quand je le
camp genevois après je suis d'accord
avec nico et ébène
il se trouve qu'il est intéressant boli
fédé et que tu intéressant ce qui bouge
bien il est il est actif sur des
situations de spots up ou quand ils
arrivent à 45° il tourne sur les
situations de mange pas coach mais ça
doit s'appeler que je prends curl à 45
degrés tu dis peut s'élever pour tirer
il faire ces choses là après moi je
trouve que son antre de l'est pas bon et
qu en fait dans une nba on recherche des
joueurs grecs qui on va donner un rôle
ou deux au tour de deux des leaders de
l'équipe
est ce qu'on va lui demander on va le
mans et de développer des choses oui
potentiellement faire de meilleurs choix
parce qu'il a un en carrière initiés il
a un ratio de positiver de paires de
base négatif il ya 98 passes décisives
122 pertes de balle dans sa carrière car
initiés
mais en même temps je pense qu'on va
surtout lui demandez pas de défendre les
ailiers adverses est maître des tyrans
spots up
donc si si le s'il arrive en fait à
devenir élite sur ceux sur ces deux
compartiments sur ces deux compartiments
il misera pas autre chose
et s'il n'est pas bon sur ces deux
compartiments il aura besoin d'autre
chose pour vivre une vie
oui mais combien disent que sur nos
spots up when liesse et c'est
l'excellent enix qui vous que et encore
il y vraiment que sur 10 potter points
bien aujourd'hui mais comme j -cr odeurs
et bien sûr du scooter que détient en
spots la chapelle droit mais jack warden
défend fouqueray cela doit peser sur
nous traînent pas mal plus de 2 de poids
que ça ne le font pas capable de
fonctionner car les le jeu offensivement
je presse du jour quand il faut mettre
dans les dents les modèles d'attac avec
les équipes qui jouent beaucoup de pick
and roll et qui ça le fait que des les
meneurs et beaucoup de la charge la
création offensive et qu'ils fassent pas
mal de couleuvres ça limite la
répartition des tirs est donc en fait
les ailiers il faut que du spo te sauf
si tu as des ailiers sur dominant mais
moi j'ai pas trop d'un jeu pas trop
confiance sur son sur son développement
d'autres choses que le tir si j'achète
le joueur si j'achète kessler edwards
dans dans entre 25 et 35 on va dire
c'est parce que j'espère qu'il jouera
les outils de son corps pour
potentiellement embêter les ailiers
adverses et dépendre et je vois ça doit
sentir comme une arme plutôt fiable
alors êtes vous confiant les uns les
autres sur sa capacité à défendre que
s'ils ne fait que ce côté il va falloir
qu'ils soient un défenseur plus plus non
moi je crois pas après je ne sais pas si
les autres développent durable
je trouve très naïf en défense
ça saute la moindre feinte et pourtant
il joue pas contre contre des recrues 5
étoiles sur les pick and roll défensif
tout ce qui est rotations c'est c'est à
la limite du risible
par moments je fais très dur mais parce
que je m'attendais à autre chose en fait
avant deux je l'avais quittée j'avais
regardé que daylight l'an dernier
j'avais pas regardé le match entier de
pepperdine mais du coup je m'étais fait
une autre image du joueur
il ya des il ya des moments où il se lie
bien où tu te dis ah il va peut-être
pouvoir switcher et puis après ils se
retrouvent face à un petit puis je le
trouve lourd donc
à chaque fois il se prend les écrans il
reste bloqué dans les écrans là on va se
dire oui cdc des petites choses il va
progresser mais je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de petites choses à faire
progresser chez lui mais je sais pas
peut-être eu une carrière quand même
assez étrange à peu près de la rue s'est
améliorée
physiquement et sur le terrain de
manière drastique
d'année en année mais ce soit il s'est
vraiment souvent une équipe qui a pas de
formes défensivement ce qui indispose
équipe qui joue rien de systématique
donc moi je crois que ça va dépendre du
contexte dans lequel j'évolue ce soit
construit se ramassent à sacramento
mes excuses à nico sur twitter
ce sera pas simple un endroit comme
sacramento c'est sûr qu'il ne viendrait
jamais un défenseur plus plus mais je
crois que dans le propre contexte on
parle d'un gars qui physiquement et
psychologiquement a continué de
s'améliorer d'année en année et que oui
il peut donner un bond de france a alors
parle-nous de cette psychologie
ce qui est intéressant avec karl kastler
edward c'est que justement il n'y a pas
été drafté du tout pas été tracées par
ont peu été recrutés du tout pour son
profil physique
je répète à 18 ans il faisait un moyen
de 96 et 70 kg si vous regardez sa photo
sur espn collège porte ils ne se
ressemblent pas du tout il a l'air
d'avoir 12 ans il était classé 73e
au total et il était le reçu une offre
d'un peu près d'ein qui était je crois à
ce l'offre parce qu' aucune autre école
la liste d'offres qui a été fait à 88
parce que son frère joué si vous
rappelez de lui son frère c'est cameron
a world skies joué à peu perdre haleine
pendant l'an dernier il a joué à pau
pendant quatre ans et joue maintenant en
belgique
et justement c'est un jeune joueur qui
jamais été capable de surfer par dessus
la compétition que jamais été capable de
laisser ses talents athlétiques parler
et qui a fallu qu'ils mettent le travail
dans le d'année en année condamnés
puissent on peut le voir danser dans ses
entrevues d'après match qui sont somme
toute g
mais on se voit on voit que kastler
edwards se rappelle des autres années
mais les choses en perspective donc ça
c'est quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup
je jouais il parlait de la victoire
contre california regardez aujourd'hui
dire on l'a perdue contre l'année
dernière puis on a mal joué on était on
n'était pas capable on n'a pas été
capables de tirer le meilleur de nous
mêmes on s'est vengé cette année j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup cette capacité là
justement à pau vivre de match en match
qui skie vraiment le cob j'ai beaucoup
de jeunes joueurs ils voient ils voient
seulement le prochain match
pokernews donc moi j'aime j'aime
beaucoup ce profil un peu en dehors je
crois qu yves qui va mettre le travail
qu'il faut physiquement et sur le
terrain pour donner un bon joueur alan
ne montrent ils pas de dureté et je
parle pas seulement de son poids moi je
trouve qu'il est un peu léger du poids
mais en règle générale dureté mentale
heurtée six
je suis honnête les la visualisation de
ces quelques matches la dernière
maussade et je les ai pas regardé
pendant deux mois je suis je suis un peu
déçu en fait défensivement je vends pas
mal tout ce qu'a dit ce qu'a dit nico je
le trouve soft c'est dur mais je le
trouve un peu soft je trouve
j'ai c'est comme si c'est c11 gouard
dans le corps théorique d'un ailier mais
il n'a pas la dureté pour pas pour
défendre les 3/4 quoi en dans le monde
professionnel il à ce qu'a dit nico sûr
il manque beaucoup les feintes
ça m'a assez déçu notamment contre 11,1
gaffe à la keith perty là il faisait une
feinte ça sautait qui se perd tu
appelles prenez les contacts et c'est
prenez des lancers ou alors se décaler
pouvait tirer assez facilement donc
c'est un meilleurs jouets de je pense
que c'est un genre en fait ça a validé
les deux points suite j'ai l'impression
ben dis quoi il s'est encore un joueur
qui est pas mature et donc on peut
acheter les outils et acheter le corps
pour que ça marche je suis vraiment
d'accord mais en même temps je le trouve
un peu je le trouve très naïf est un peu
un peu sortent sur les contacts et ça ça
me fait ça me fait ça me fait peur et
c'est par un joueur dur c'est un joueur
c'est pas ses papiers boston ou zaïre
williams mais c'est un joueur qui
explose j'ai l'impression sur pas mal de
contacts et moi c'est quelque chose qui
sur les ailiers qui me fait qui me fait
très peur surtout d'effectivement pour
sa défense même si c'est moi qui
l'opposait à défendre maintenant mais
c'était le seul qui était pas tout à
fait ridicule façade routine ua lors des
deux matches car il a contesté on va
dire les instruits passe le drop timide
nico est ce que tu as des choses à
ajouter sur le côté manière
psychologique inaptitude jeu j'aime
beaucoup les détails que qui ont pu être
menée par ben parce que effectivement ça
comme on dit à la nhtsa boucle la boucle
de la discussion dans le sens où où
effectivement il a grandi sur le tard il
a peut-être pas encore encaissé
il a pas la dureté d'un 4 pour l'instant
certains coaches je dise que ça se
travaille d'autres malades nous dit on
la commente hull évaluerait quoi
compliquer du coup moi on me l'avait
vendu comme un frêne dit j'ai vu les
trois j'ai pas vu le dire pour l'instant
donc du coup pour l'évaluation son
avenir en nba va passer par par plus de
dureté par assimiler ce nouveau corps
rajoutez quelques kilos et puis arrêtez
de reculer de 3 cm à chaque fois que
quelqu'un vient poser son avant-bras sur
moi donc ça c'est honteux c'est aux
états unis c'est possible il va passer
un été il va prendre 5 6 kg de muscles
et puis ça sera pas le même joueur et on
dira oh là là on a franchement je m'y
attendais pas donc il peut devenir un
frenchie oui pour l'instant pour moi
c'est qu'un flux ben est ce que tu as
une comparaison dont l'idée moi je n'ai
eu une mais je pense qu'elle n'est pas
bonne dans l'idée est qu être moi je
sais que ça a la rude c'est pour
rejoindre que j'aime beaucoup mais je le
vois un peu comme un plus grand si james
gunn qui peut tirer en sortant des crins
et qui peut tirer un spotter et qui
défend qui défend bien sans vraiment
défendre
moi j'allais dire c'est dit andré hunter
maigre c'est pas quand c'est pour quand
c'est pas encore dire de rentrer à des
processus trop d'accord
ouais ouais je vois vraiment ce que je
veux dire dans le corps moi c'est le
corps dans la peau d'un super bon sur le
début de saison car il est blessé mais
oui une bouée nommé riboud le deuxième
s'élance et ses instruments
ouais ça ce n'est pas qu'on la première
mais ça se passe super bien pour lui
parce qu'il ait bahi s'y adapter et
maintenant il sait mettre les trois
points et défendre à venir il était
pendu comme défensif mais c'était faux
c'est vrai et c'est là qu'on voit c'est
à vous ça peut faire peur pour edward
puisque hunter était bien meilleur
qu'edward défensivement en ciel il a
quand même galéré en nba haute à ses
débuts parce que
cerny monde ovale ont évolué et d'un
autre côté il ya des joueurs qu'on pende
sauf qu'on croit trop maigre et qui s'en
sortent très bien assez dit je pense à
notre ami mcdaniels a fait de même et c
est tant mieux pour lui d'ailleurs
et tant mieux pour manu il est bienvenu
chez les hommes alors vous avez tous
parlé du ring 30 25 35
plus on serbe de joueurs qu'on se rend
compte que facile à chaque fois la même
mayonnaise mais on se rend compte qu'il
ya de plus en plus de joueurs qui
pourraient prétendre à ces positions là
ça va être très difficile de les classer
est ce que pour l'instant il y est pour
vous d'en être dans un top 35 allait
prendre son tour 35 oui bataille pas top
30 encore je trouve que comme nico y
alla m'en parler les derniers matches
peut attendre les derniers deux trois
semaines on était quand même assez
décevant pour l'instant top 35 36 oh
ouais je léger ajustement hobbit port de
il est 30e mais dans un groupe entre 25
et 40
c'est les mêmes la même chose mais ouais
il est gelé dans mon top 35 hockey hugo
d'avant nouveau perdu nico je veux je
veux finir à pardon j'avais mis mon je
m'étais mis en oeuvre je ne sais pas je
parlais tout seul donc pour moi il est
au deuxième tour pour l'instant mais
j'ai pas encore vraiment mis en avant
comme à celui de la feda year de choses
pour ceux qui nous écoutent qui écoutent
ce podcast vous pouvez évidemment aller
voir sa fiche sur notre site envergure
point ces eaux
le spécialiste de la zone du côté de
notre team de spécialistes régionaux
près dieu nous seconde marcel perdu sur
twitter va vous faire une petite fiche
aux petits oignons
il suit beaucoup cette conférence encore
plus que les membres du podcast ce soir
et puis autre chose si vous allez voir
notre big board donc notre classement de
raska 2021 ne le prenez pas pour quelque
chose d'acquis pour l'instant on est
largement en train de l'affiner on n'a
même pas encore complètement affiner les
différents classements en espèces du
temps donc deuxième tour pour une unique
au deuxième tour un peu pour tout le
monde mais de plutôt début de deuxième
tour pour baigner comme ça je voulais
finir sur rapidement mais on a parlé de
lui en début de caste l'autre joueur de
perdre et le meneur ou est-ce qui va
aller déjà pour le présenter rapidement
un 85 81 kg 37% à 3 points sur sa
carrière 85% lancé le français serait
carrément ville dès le moyen-âge et est
donc belle donc ben leber
comment tu vois la suite de salies à col
virus déjà chez le coiffeur viala
d'avoir une et plants d'oignons sur la
galette cambi colbert race c'est un peu
comme les joies que vous créez un malien
à une billettique et lorsque vous voulez
faire un jour à vos profs dimensions et
que vous lui vous le
mettez 20 $ sur lui en toute hâte
shooting ne joue de manière absolument
il joue de manière il joue de manière
absolument irresponsable il ya un niveau
des usages qui doit approcher celui de
2,2 russell westbrook et il fait pas ça
il me fait penser un peu à une version à
une version meneur de jimmer fredette
whisky brand absolument tout est ce
qu'ils décident absolument où tout ce
qui se passe
j'ai de la difficulté à voir un billet
le voir de raft et peut-être jeudi à
marcus paige avait été drafté il
chérissait
le meneur ni de yuans 6 et quelques
années je dois jouer maintenant au japon
quelque chose à vous joindre servi
et voilà qu'ils ont je crois japon ce
japon servi je sais que le japon l'a vu
sacré joue au japon vient pas gagné le
concours de danse mais mais c'est ça je
crois qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d'avenir
une bible pour quelqu'un comme lui si
peut pas s'adapter un rôle de
spécialiste absolument extraordinaire
pense vous rappelez vous de petten siva
qui jouait louis v ya quelques années
qu'ils étaient venus dimensions
similaires qui ont pu s'adapter comme un
rôle de défenseur à biesheim qui était
juste pas assez gros je vois je vois mal
r'n'b que quelqu'un castrés doit lé
service colbras je le vois mal évolué en
nba mais je pourrais me tromper je
voyais mal fred van littérale nba c'est
ça je n'ai pas donné lé ton frère invite
qui est un peu sorti toutes les sauces à
l'anme j'allais dire est qu'il peut être
un challenge bronson en fait il est il a
déjà repoussé son petit mais qui sont
quand même fort lui je trouve petit et
un peu
oui un peu lp pensez un joueur qui joue
en pro a rob gray qui jouent aux états
unis keita youssou maintenant mes
regrets beaucoup plus élégant que colby
roscoff bureau s'il faut il est livré
avec un doliprane tu regardes pas de
match sans a appris tant de diplômés ben
moi je les trouvais je veux en fait je
trouve que cette année il est plus en
difficulté parce qu'en fait je l'avais
vu l'année dernière dans un match qu'on
tue aussi au tout début de saison donc
c'était il ya longtemps et pour voir au
congo et je crois que il en met 30 ou 35
tout seul contre lui aussi à l'extérieur
et là il y avait vraiment ce délire de
hockey créateurs sur pick'n roll peuple
où loeb de loin peut scorer et assez
wade il et je vois ce que nico veut dire
il n'est pas très élégant proche du
panier pour pour terminer il est trés
dans la rupture mais c'est quand même
assez quand même un joueur qui est à 114
matchs sympas torse titularisation
initiés qui fait quatre ans car 40% des
pas décisifs pour qui est sur le terrain
c'est énorme donc son avenir en nba
ces bacs à fleurs et backup meneur
faudra qu'il fasse moins de perte de vol
parce qu'il en fait quand même pas mal
mais en même temps il prend des risques
il a beaucoup il a tout temps la balle
mais voilà foot il faut qu'il faut
qu'ils tirent et là qui l'a 84 % aux
lancers francs en carrière en ski et 37%
à 3 points art qui prend du coup la
prend très peu de spotter c'est des très
bons chiffres en vrai je pense juste que
physiquement ça peut être un peu un peu
compliqué il ya toujours des contre
exemples comme tu l'as dit vente dite
brunson cédé contre exemple mais je
pense qu'il sera potentiellement un bon
jour en europe plus qu'un il ya un
backup nba mais je peux me tromper
c'est un joueur que j'aime bien et que
j'aurai d'amour top avant la draft part
peut-être pas 60 mais je veux vraiment
ça me donne 100 guillou à elegar bruit
c'est pas la garde et houston avec la
petite mercy qui joue qui joua le vent
oh mais il est magnifique j'adorerais ce
jour-là une sémantique d'irresponsables
regret en acier
beaucoup de noir annoncé un responsable
complet à la mission des responsables
sympathique
or ce jour ah oui génial je suis content
actions en france c'est un bon c'est
austin rivers sur la côte
non mais oui je l adore les mérites
il mérite tout ce qui se fait pour je
suis content vous avez fait ma journée
j'avais oublié que galles existait peu
je me rappelle non pour mettre en
contexte parce que peut-être que 40%
d'assists ça parle pas grand monde
jam oren sur sa deuxième année il est à
peine la plus que ça alors est-ce qu'on
peut mettre un gros bémol là dessus le
le projet technique de peur dan en
attaque ou en défense a été confiée à
gilbert montagné lorenzo romain alors
est ce retard mais c'est pareil
mais lorenzo a expliqué à ceux qui
écoutent il a tué des démarques elfen
lied et c'est lui qui ressemblait à rien
à washington et après qu il qu'il y
avait une vraie carrière nba et lui
annonce que du coup les il dribble
tellement il a tellement la balle que
c'est un peu quand on quand on nous dit
russell westbrook s'est impliqué coeur
parce qu'on regarde juste les
analytiques
je suis pas en train de comparer les
deux écoles bureaux scié il lui arrive
même pas à la cheville mais mais là sur
ce coup là ça donne l'impression de
l'analytique oran le tableau un peu plus
joli qu'il ne l'est vraiment moi ce qui
me gêne beaucoup ses crocs qu'ils
fassent des ponts entre le le pectoral
et le bral mais il ya du petit gras quoi
ça n'a pas dit non mais ça va pas du
tout il est chaud dit il est un peu de
shopping ou bien un très gros maria
toujours fait ça en vrai il aime bien
les confits la création à un meneur un
peu petit mais des shooteurs au tour à
washington il ya eu il ya eu à zahia
thomas s'il ya eu fuite comme tu l'as
dit fo s'était pas laissée pas réglé non
mais c'était en vo mettra création toute
la création de la taxe dans ton honneur
et je veux comme ça même si avec annette
robinson qui qu'ils aient des stades pas
mal avec washington sous sous omar et
après il s'est fait virer pour des
scandales un peu bizarre il était en
arizona il a retrouvé un job à
pepperdine donc il était assistant
arizona de ça en bon c'est pas notre
coach préféré
moi je pense qu'on pourrait le voir dans
un an un match de pcl où il jouerait à
minsk ou non un club il mettrait des
points bien sûr franchiront recevoir et
supprime une bonne carrière et pourrait
faire une bonne ce mur dit si on avait
une semaine aussi c'est en tout cas un
niveau des stats quoi c'est vrai qu'au
niveau du style de jeu c'est pas facile
à regarder des ford elle n'a pas pris un
immense plaisir et ça fait et ça fait
mal de le lire parce que c'est une
équipe qu'on aimerait bien aimé voir ils
ont dû découvrir sympa c'est une petite
fac dans une conférence pas très grand
cerf los angeles à malibu ça se sent
la plage ou est ce qui est toujours déjà
embedone c'est ça enfin bon voilà pour
pour kessler et douars c'est donc paul
biro ce qu'ont été rhabillée pour balle
était à malibu mais bon keszler edwards
reste à surveiller
vous l'aurez compris parce que les bains
il est grand et it shoes et donc ça ça
vaut cher on l'a vu à maintes et maintes
reprises lors de ses dernières drap donc
ne pas sous-estimer les grands empires
et pour le reste envergure point ces
eaux où notre compte twitter ne compta
ça pour des vidéos sympathique le compte
youtube aussi pourquoi pas allez ciao
tout le monde